hello everyone welcome to another
episode of Science and Technology q a
for kids and others and I see there are
a whole bunch of questions saved up or
sent in from our submission form
so let me see what I can do with these
and I think our theme
for these Q as about science and
technology is ask questions that
you've kind of always wondered about the
answer but they seem too uh somehow too
simple to actually ask I'll try to
answer them not sure if I'll be able to
all right Universe within asks could the
expansion of the universe affect
biological evolution
it's an interesting question
uh
the
first question I suppose is
does the expansion of the universe
affect the conditions here on Earth
and the answer is certainly at the
beginning of the universe the universe
started very small at the big bang and
very hot and its expansion is what
caused the the universe to cool down and
the force of gravity to be able to form
things like galaxies and stars and so on
so in that sense the the very existence
of the Earth
it owes itself to the expansion of the
universe but if we ask about the
universe as it is today and does its
expansion affect life on Earth
um and evolution on on Earth I think
that's a more tenuous question
for example here's something that the
expansion of the universe probably
affects which is the fact that the night
sky is dark
because if you imagine if you if the
universe for example was you kind of
look out in a certain direction in the
universe and the question is is what you
see a star or is it is there no star at
least no star that's reasonably bright
and it's partly because of the expansion
of the universe there are several
different effects that contribute to the
night sky being dark one is the universe
is finite there's only a limited number
of stars you could even ever see going
as you look sort of out to the edge of
the universe so to speak another is that
gravity clumps stars together so instead
of having this kind of uniform shell of
stars of a certain distance out stars
are clumped in galaxies and clusters of
galaxies and so on and the third is that
the very fact that the Universe expands
is expanding means that stars that are
further away have the light from those
stars as shifted so that it's in effect
less well it's it's redshifted it's
shifted from something that looks like
the the the white light of the sun to
something that's redder and red and
redder and redder and when you reach
sort of the edge of the universe it's
been so shifted that it's actually no
longer visible light it's microwaves
that have a very frequency
so
I don't know to what extent uh evolution
of life on Earth is affected by the fact
that there are these cycles of light and
dark
um we could certainly imagine being on a
planet where one face of the planet is
locked in the um in the towards a star
and the other faces is away from the
Star for example Mercury causes planet
to the sun has that feature with respect
to the sun one one side of mercury is
constantly locked so that it's facing
the sun and the other is facing away
just as the moon as it circles the Earth
it's locked so that we always see the
same side of the moon and the Far Side
of the Moon is away from us that kind of
locking occurs because the the in the
Moon is
although it's made of rockets slightly
deformable and the deformations of the
Moon Over time cause it to kind of their
sort of tidal deformations they pull out
in One Direction and squash down another
direction as that happens over time it
will gradually lock the moon's rotation
to be such that it's synchronized with
the Earth in such a way that it keeps
one face towards the Earth but I I don't
know whether the if there was a planet
that if our if our Earth had been
tidally locked so that one side of it
was always in light and one side it was
always in dark would that have
fundamentally affected biological
evolution I'm not sure
there's one effect that perhaps we can
think of as being somewhat of
cosmological origin and that's the
preponderance of right-handed molecules
in Biochemistry of a left-handed ones so
when you make a biochemical molecule
like sugar for example if you look at
the arrangement of atoms you can have
kind of a a sequence of atoms where that
you can have the same atoms but it's as
if you're kind of curling one the set of
atoms around like your left hand with
one atom sticking out like your thumb or
you're curling around the other way so
that those same atoms are curled around
like your right hand with the thumb
sticking up so there are two different
chiralities two different handednesses
that are possible for something like
sugar glucose
um
and uh those if you just sort of throw
the atoms together to make sugar you'll
get equal numbers of left and
right-handed sugar molecules but somehow
biological life doesn't work that way
biological life always makes
right-handed sugar molecules
and in a sense by the time you've got
sort of life that's always making
right-handed molecules the processes by
which it makes new molecules will tend
to always lead those molecules to be
right-handed rather than left-handed
ones
by the way for most people if you if you
eat left hand sugar most people find
left kind of sugar doesn't taste sweet
um the uh it's so there are the chemical
reactions on our tongues that lead to
taste uh are affected by whether they're
right or left-handed molecules but when
we just sort of throw the atoms together
to make molecules it doesn't uh give us
more right-handed than left-handed
molecules so that's something sort of
special to life
so the question is why did we wind up
with right-handed rather than
left-handed molecules in life and it
could be that that's just a pure sort of
accident of history and once they were a
little bit more right-handers than
left-handers so to speak and this is I'm
talking about molecules not at the level
of uh of actual handedness of us and the
way that our brains are laid out
um the uh you know it could be that
that's a sort of a slight preponderance
of right-handed molecules and then those
ones were able to interact more easily
with right-handed ones and so the
left-handed ones uh kind of lost the
game but there's a question of can we
derive the fact that it's mostly
right-handed molecules and that they got
the advantage
but maybe the answer is yes and I think
one theory of that is that
when there are certain processes where
sort of handedness matters so most of
the time if if you were to just take
pictures of you know billiard balls
bouncing off each other or for that
matter atoms bouncing off each other
most of the time you would kind of take
those pictures and you would be able to
say here's the picture and now let's
invert the coordinates so let's let's
take every Everything which was going
left to right make it go right to left
invert everything the picture that you
get from inverting everything would look
just as convincing just as plausible as
the picture you get without inverting
things in other words sort of as far as
the basic laws of physics are concerned
it seems as if everything is invariant
with respect to inverting the directions
of space
so that so that that's sort of in the
first approximation that's what's true
now it turns out in the mid-1950s it was
discovered that that isn't always true
there are subtle effects where you can
tell the difference between kind of the
the the the correct the the the the
inverted version and the non-inverted
version and one occurs sort of in the
physics of the earth so to speak here
and the other does not
so the particular phenomenon where that
was first identified is radioactive beta
decay so that's something that happens
in nuclei that sort of have too many
neutrons relative to protons the what
will happen is and sometimes the other
way around as well but that's slightly
different different phenomenon but
basically you'll you'll have you'll emit
an electron as your neutrino and your
Neutron will turn into a proton so that
happens for example if you've just stuff
too many neutrons to go along with a
single proton they'll Decay Away by
emitting by emitting electrons and
turning into protons and so on okay so
in any case that phenomenon you can ask
the following question you have a
nucleus
that's decaying by emitting an electron
the um
there's sort of a question of whether if
you make the make the nucleus spin in a
certain direction will the electrons be
emitted uh kind of will they will they
will they care which direction the
nucleus is spinning in in terms of which
way they go
why does that matter
well the point is that when you are
looking at kind of a a top spinning and
you look at a top spinning you look at
in a mirror the um let's see how to
think this through uh essentially the
the the
sort of
spinning of things where there's an axis
and a rotation doesn't invert in a
mirror the same way that just pure
directions of things invert so fancy
mathematical way to say it is there are
vectors which are kind of like just
motion of things and there are so-called
axial vectors which are things that
represent an axis with rotation axis
with rotation doesn't invert in the way
that that pure vectors pure directions
invert
so if you're asking a question does
everything sort of invert the same way
if it matters which kind of which way
things are spinning then you you get um
you don't get the same inversion let's
be more specific let's say we're dealing
with a particular kind of particle let's
pick a neutrino
slightly obscure particle but relevant
for these purposes
as a neutrino
goes along it's going in a certain
direction neutrino is also spinning it's
a on its axis and the question is how is
the direction in which neutrino is going
aligned with the direction that neutrino
is spinning in and the thing that was
implicitly discovered in the mid-1950s
and then clarified a little bit later is
that neutrinos are always kind of
left-handed when they there if you look
at the direction of their spin relative
to the direction of their emotion it
always forms kind of a left-handed thing
with the thumb representing the motion
and the fingers curling around the
direction of the spin
and that means that as you sort of work
that through the end result of all of
that is it matters in because in beta
Decay neutrinos are emitted neutrinos
are always left-handed to compensate for
that the electrons end up being having a
certain handedness or the or the
distribution of where the electrons come
out relative to the spinal nucleus is
affected anyway a variety of different
ways to say it but the end result is
that in regulator beta Decay the
electrons that are emitted tend to
always have oh is it right hand or
left-handed I'm not sure maybe maybe
they're right-handed to compensate for
the left-handed instant machine I'm not
sure but anyway so there's a so when the
electrons come out there is a there's
sort of a difference between there's
there's more right-handed ones in the
sense that they their direction of spin
is let's say anti-aligned with the
direction of motion and less left-handed
ones
so what
well the the hypothesis would be
that uh
there is radioactive beta Decay that
occurred on the early Earth
and the result the reason for that is
because carbon 14 is produced so carbon
is usually carbon-12 that means it's a
carbon atom with six protons and six
neutrons so a total of 12 uh
particles in in the nucleus but there's
also a version of carbon carbon 14 that
has an extra two neutrons and carbon 14
decays through beta Decay and carbon 14
is produced by cosmic rays that come
from uh particles from the Sun
and um the uh
and so those are that's produced in the
atmosphere of the early Earth you get
carbon 14 it decays the electrons and
the carbon 14 Decay are preferentially a
particular handedness the fact that
those electrons are just sort of uh
hanging out on the early Earth tend to
be preferentially of a particular
handedness then the theory goes that
affects the chemical reactions that
occur and it tips the balance a little
bit in the direction of having
right-handed sugar rather than
left-handed sugar that's a hypothesis
for how things get to be sort of
right-handed rather than left-handed
it's a way in which well not quite
cosmology but at least astrophysics
affects uh an aspect of that's been
burnt into the evolution of life on
Earth
it's a general question the extent to
which things like spins of particles and
so on affect chemistry mostly in
chemistry it's just a question of where
did the electron go not or maybe maybe
how does an electron interact with
another electron but but not sort of how
does particularly when it comes to
nuclei and so on it's not usually it
doesn't usually matter to chemistry
which way the spin of a nucleus goes but
there's some hypothesis that a few
phenomena like for example famously the
magnetic field sensing apparatus of
pigeons
um might be making use of the
interaction of of uh spins of particles
with things so a rather long answer and
I think the the basic answer is that I
don't know of of uh really good
connections between so the cosmology of
things and the evolution of life on
Earth
um
let's see
the question here how much does the sky
weigh how much does the Earth weigh
well
the it's
what does way mean
way is how much force is there as a
result of gravity
when uh pulling something that you've
got down towards the center of the earth
so weight is usually defined as the
something that depends on the force with
which gravity is pulling on something
but that force is proportional to the
mass of the object what is the mass a
mass of an object is usually defined in
terms of if you push the object with a
certain Force how much will it
accelerate Newton's second law says
Force equals mass times acceleration so
the amount of acceleration is is uh the
is proportional to the force divided by
the mass of the object the heavier the
object the harder you're going to have
to push it to get it to accelerate a
certain amount that's the so-called
inertial mass of an object is what
determines how much how much sort of
resistance to starting motion there is
now it turns out basic fact about
physics is that the inertial masses of
objects also that the mass quantity that
appears in that uh characteristic of
inertia
um is also the same quantity that
appears in determining how much
gravitational force there will be on an
object
the force of gravity is proportional to
the mass of one object to the force of
gravity between two objects is the mass
of one object multiplied by the mass of
the other object and then divided by the
distance squared and multiplied by the
gravitational constant but that gives
you the force between those two objects
and it's a it's a fact so-called
equivalence principle that says that the
inertial mass of an object the
resistance to acceleration is the same
mass that appears in the gravitational
mass and that is what determines the uh
what we that that that gravitational
mass is what determines the weight the
amount of gravitational force that pulls
an object towards the center of the
Earth
now if you say how much does the Earth
weigh in common language will typically
mean what's the we could mean both
what's the force of gravity pulling on
something to say what does it weigh and
what's the mass of the thing because
those are those are mathematically
equivalent or it's physically equivalent
so
but when we talk about weight of things
on the earth we usually mean how much
does the earth pull on the thing so for
example if we took the thing to the Moon
where the the gravity at the surface is
one sixth the gravity on the surface of
the Earth then we'd say the thing weighs
one-sixth as much even though the mass
of the object would be the same
so when we ask how much does the Earth
weigh
that's kind of a funny question it
probably what we really mean is what's
the mass of the Earth
and um the uh
that um
um
is uh uh is something perfectly well
defined the mass of the earth is what
determines both the the inertial uh the
way that the the Earth is its motion is
affected by forces and so on and also
the amount of gravity that the Earth
feels say from the Sun and that the moon
for example feels from the Earth
so can we work out what the mass of the
earth is well let's see
can we do that I don't uh immediately
remember the mass of the earth I I
actually vaguely remember it's 10 to 26
kilograms but that might be wrong let's
work it out
okay so uh
the Earth the um
uh the radius of the Earth
is let's see it's it's it's equatorial
circumference is about 24 000 miles so
that means that it's that where 2 pi R
means that which is the um or uh the
diameter of the Earth would then be 8
000 miles based on that because it's the
circumference divided by
um uh
divided by pi and we kind of know it's
000 miles around the Earth because it's
kind of like a uh the 24 time zones we
know it's about a thousand miles per
time zone we can kind of estimate that
even from knowing about the US it's us
about three time zones and um and so on
so then Okay so we've we've worked out
then that the the radius
is that right the radius would be four
thousand miles and then the volume of
the Earth would be four thirds pi R
cubed which is four thousand miles uh
times
um uh let's see I'm pretty bad at this
mental arithmetic it's like five times
the cube of four thousand the cube of
four thousand is uh well
um uh four cubed is 64.
um let's see thousand would be ten to
the three ten to the nine uh 64 times
ten to the nine and let's say times five
would be about
um uh would be uh 10 to the 11. so that
would be 10 to the 11 cubic miles for
the volume of the Earth
okay so that if that's the volume of the
Earth
then each mile each cubic mile is about
well it's about
um uh what 1760 yards in a mile if I
remember right this is a terrible memory
exercise for me you know you can just
type this into wealth malfo and see what
the answer is maybe I should just do
that just to actually get it right but
let's let's keep doing the mental
arithmetic okay just see whether we can
get it right so it's 10 to the 11 cubic
miles and it's each cubic mile
is um
uh about
um
each cubic mile is let's say two
thousand uh meters on a side so that's
um uh 2000 meters is um uh cube of that
is 10 to the nine times so that'd be 10
to the 10 cubic meters per cubic mile so
that's 10 to the 11 cubic miles times 10
to the 10 uh cubic meters per cubic mile
that's 10 to the 21 cubic meters so
that's our estimate for the volume of
the Earth 10 to 21 cubic meters
and then
the next thing we need to know is if
we're trying to work out the mass of the
Earth what's the density of the earth so
the density of water is one gram per
cubic centimeter the density of rock is
about 5 grams per cubic centimeter and
so that means that is per cubic meter so
if it's if it's
um uh 5 grams per cubic
um
centimeter that means
um each cubic centimeter is 1 100th of a
meter on the side so that means it's um
uh the um
uh so there's a hundred centimeters
going into one meter so 100 cubed just
10 to this is
um uh 10 to the sixth so that's five
times ten to the sixth
um grams
uh and in kilograms that will be 5000
kilograms so that's five thousand
kilograms times 10 to the 21 would be
five uh five thousand kilograms times 10
to the 21 would be uh 10 to the um uh 10
to the uh 24 5 times 10 to the 24. so
our estimate based on this terrible
mental arithmetic is 5 times 10 to the
24 uh uh kilograms for the mass of the
Earth and now I have to go just um uh
use both mouth and type in mass of the
Earth let's see how far off I am
oh my gosh 6 times 10 to the 24
kilograms we win
cool
all right I'm impressed that I can still
do any kind of mental arithmetic I have
to say as a matter of educational
history uh I was always when I was a kid
I was always just wretched at doing well
at remembering things like
multiplication tables and I I gradually
over the course of my life I've I have a
decent memory as maybe you can tell from
these live streams
um and uh you know I've gradually filled
in different multiplication facts but
for example in that piece of mental
arithmetic we just had to do which I'm
very proud of having gotten more or less
right
um the uh
uh the um uh you know most of what we
were doing was adding things and the
occasional multiplication but it was
only an approximate multiplication that
we didn't need to remember that 7 times
8 was 56 that was the one multiplication
fact that I learned when I was uh seven
years old I think because it was the one
multiplication fact other people could
never remember so I always sort of came
out ahead by just knowing that one fact
but any case
um
so
uh
let's see well so the question was that
was the question of how much does the
Earth weigh so we've learned it's 5
times 10 to 24 kilograms
um and uh
uh by the way
yeah so now the question was how much
does the sky weigh
more tricky so
uh let's imagine that we were to take
um
let's see how to work this out
the question is if we took all the gas
that's in the atmosphere and put it in a
box
how much would that box weigh
so let's see how we would work that out
what do we know
we know the pressure
hmm
you know this might be a Oscar from
Alpha
uh I'm going to I'm just going to say
maths of Earth's atmosphere let's see if
we actually know it
um
I think we could uh oh yes we do fives
times ten to the 18 kilograms
so that means that the um that's kind of
interesting that that is telling us
that the mass of the atmosphere is about
one millionth the mass of the Earth
so one millionth of the mass of the of
the solid earth one millionth is the gas
that's in the atmosphere it's kind of an
interesting number actually and I wonder
how that uh uh for other planets I
wonder whether there's an easy piece of
scaling that you can do so for example
for Mars the atmosphere I wonder whether
we know what um uh what the mass of
Mars's atmosphere is
um
let me see oh yes
10 to the 16 kilograms so now I'm
curious if we work out the mass of
Mars's atmosphere divided by a mass of
Mars itself I guess it's going to be
significantly smaller than
um
uh let's see
as soon as atmosphere
uh
let me see
can we work this out oh very strange
it's not
telling us the answer to that that's odd
oh I see
I see I see I see
it was confused
uh okay it's four times ten to the minus
eight so uh it's about
um so that means that in the case of
Mars the atmosphere is a smaller
fraction of the mass of the whole planet
than it is on Earth it's it's uh
um uh roughly 60 times smaller for Mars
the the atmosphere is a 60 times smaller
fraction of the total mass than is on
earth now for Jupiter goes the other way
around for Jupiter it's kind of all
atmosphere no solid thing there's
probably a solid core to Jupiter right
at the center but it's mostly sort of
all atmosphere and all gas
so I I'm I'm going to make the guess
that as you look at well for for smaller
planets a smaller things like the moon
or even like Mercury
um the uh uh the the the thing that um
uh all of the gas will have escaped I'm
now curious about Venus and whether in
the case of Venus
oh fascinating okay so for Venus the
mass of the atmosphere is is almost the
same as it is for for
uh no actually it's it's ten times
larger
no 100 times larger than the mass
relative to the mass of the planet as it
is on Earth okay so my my potential
hypothesis that as the mass of the
planet gets higher the fraction of the
mass that is in the atmosphere goes up
doesn't seem to be correct based on the
fact that the ratio of mass for Venus
compared to the earth differs by a
factor of 100. so in any case so but we
do we did find out that that the the
atmosphere weighs about a millionth mass
of the Earth
um and I say ways in this rather vague
way because as I said as I explained
what really is the thing you can compute
is the mass not the weight as in being
pulled by the gravity of the Earth
let's see
uh
um
Jamie asks what would happen if gravity
on the earth suddenly changed to gravity
of the Moon
um What If gravity suddenly got stronger
uh
well
I mean so many things would change
um
and
it's it's one of those things where
where in physics so many things are
connected you can't just say let's just
change this one parameter change this
dial and and see what happens and
um expect everything else to remain
constant that was a theory
uh due to a well-known physicist called
Iraq originally that perhaps some of the
fundamental constants of nature might
have changed over the course of the of
the time that the Universe has been
around in particular the so-called fine
structure constant which characterizes
the well essentially the the actually
the the um I think in his theory the
gravitational constant the thing that
characterizes the strength of gravity
given two masses of a certain size how
much force of gravity will there be
between them it's possible that that
quantity could have changed in the
history of the Universe I don't think it
it has and in our Theory of physics
that's not something you would see
happen but you could imagine a Theory of
physics in which the gravitational
constant changes and that would
effectively have the result of changing
the force of gravity
and uh people have worked out a little
bit of what just changing that knob
would do to what happens in the universe
so for example in uh if you it certainly
affects greatly the expansion of the
universe to change the force of gravity
over time it also affects the Earth as I
recall the Earth
um well the distance between the Earth
and the Sun changes
um I think for some reason the Earth
itself expands
um as a result of probably a pressure
fixed pressure from the inside of the
earth and a reduced gravity pulling the
Earth together so to speak so a bunch of
changes like that and um I think there
are there are attempts to kind of map
out uh in you know the length of the day
has been gradually uh getting longer
days on the earth the time that the
Earth took the Earth to spin on its axis
was shorter
um back in the past and um this effect
of changing gravitational constant will
change that even more and I think there
have been attempts to kind of figure out
whether whether you could detect a
change of the gravitational constant
from that
um but it's really hard to to say what
happens to things when you just change
one parameter in physics and and not
others they tend to be all very
connected
uh
let's see
um
let's see a couple of questions here so
I see cam asking a full data memory card
versus an empty data memory card of the
same kind will there be a difference in
weight of those two objects due to the
filling of that data
um
it depends on how the data is encoded
I think
let me give a couple of examples
probably the answer in that particular
case is is
no
for a modern memory card
because
well and this may depend on whether it's
Dynamic Ram or static Ram all kinds of
details
but
hmm
well let me think about that for a
second
I mean essentially what one's dealing
with is
there's no difference in the number of
electrons that exist in the material so
it's not like there are there are more
electrons in the in the case of of
modern semiconductor memories it's not
like there are more electrons there than
there would otherwise be but there is a
different state of motion of those
electrons in certain cases and that
might be a way you would encode a bit
the presence of a bit might be the
presence of electrons moving and
circulating in some way as opposed to
not I mean it's not like when people
would count by collecting Pebbles or
something where you have there's a
pebble or that to represent a one or
there's no Pebble representing nothing
um instead the effect is a very subtle
one to do with potentially the motion of
electrons rather than them not being in
motion
so now you might ask the question if
there are electrons in Motion versus
electrons at rest
would that affect
the the mass of the object and the
answer is yes
um because
uh
let me see
um
I think the answer is yes yes I think
the answer is yes
I think the
the point is
that
that motion is so yes that motion is
associated with the electrons having a
higher energy than they would otherwise
have in fact in general yeah in a
semiconductor for example when an
electron can move from one place to
another it does so by increasing its
energy to the point where it can kind of
jump over the um the kind of barriers in
the in the material to reach this
conduction band where it can kind of
move freely and that requires that the
energy of the electron be higher so I
think the answer would be that there
will be a tiny effect of that term uh
that the presence of of a a one bit
probably would again it's a subtle thing
okay
the fact that there's an electron in
motion as opposed to not in motion could
have the effect of of producing a higher
mass for the for the object by how much
well we can work it out a little bit
perhaps
um
the the band Gap
uh of silicon is uh six volts which
means that the electron is going when
it's kind of just sitting you know at an
atom just hanging out in that atom as
opposed to promoted into the conduction
band where it can kind of move freely
it's kind of has to have an additional
energy of six electron volts
but the mass of an electron is about um
500 000 electron volts
so that means it's it's one that change
of energy is
um let's see am I getting this right
uh uh c squared
um
yeah I think I'm getting that right if I
have if I'm not off by a speed of light
squared which will be embarrassing
um doesn't seem quite right I think I
think there's another Factor
big factor actually
um yes there's a factor of of
um
uh well in any case the the you you can
work out I think there's a factor of 10
to the 16 that I'm 10 to the 17 that I'm
missing
um I'm pretty sure there's that factor
which means that the effect of the the
sort of the electron uh able to you know
moving around as opposed to being stuck
in one place is is I think an effect on
the mass of about uh one
um quadrillionth of the mass uh one
million billion million trillionth of
the mass
um so it's a it's a pretty small effect
but there's another piece that probably
makes this whole effect essentially zero
and it's the following thing
so you might say Well when there's a one
bit that you're storing let's have the
electron be circulating in the case to
represent a one and if there's a zero
let's have the electron just be sitting
there not circulating back in very early
computer memories
people did things like that for example
some of the earliest computer memories
were Mercury delay lines where you
literally put a pulse of sound into the
Mercury so you've got a compression wave
into the Mercury and it would circulate
around and you would remember things by
the fact that it took a while for the
for the sound wave to circulate around
you keep on amplifying it every time it
came around and that so the presence of
a of a of a a compression wave was the
presence of a one and the lack of a
compression wave was zero so there was a
definite thing that was different
between the one and the zero similarly
when ferrite core memory was a thing
that was what the very first computer I
used had that's those are little tiny
pieces of iron well actually ferrite
iron-like material
um where there either was magnetization
in a particular direction or there
wasn't magnetization in that direction
and the the bits were a one bit was
stored by the presence of magnetization
rather than the absence of magnetization
however it turns out that's not a very
electronically good thing to do to say
it's a one if there's something there
it's a zero if there's nothing there
better is to encode what you're doing in
such a way that you use essentially a
mathematical method to say I'm going to
take this sequence one zero one one zero
for example and have that represent the
presence of a of a series of ones and
have some other sequence of ones and
zeros represent a bunch of zeros a
common method is to use things called
feedback shift register sequences as a
way to encode one uh to basically uh
convert from something where
um convert to something where the number
of ones and zeros is always balanced and
so I kind of suspect that many memories
are doing that and that means that this
whole sort of counting how many times
there's a one versus a zero that won't
really be a thing and it's it's
something where they won't really be a
difference of energy between oh it's all
ones versus all zeros
but but these are
um I mean there are there are
a lot of cases where
um
one tries to for example do computer
security hacks by looking at oh you know
the thing will use a tiny bit more power
if it goes in that direction versus that
direction and using that to kind of be
able to tease out what's going on in the
chip even when you didn't uh when you
didn't um uh when when you sort of
weren't supposed to know that
anyway you're asking difficult questions
you guys are asking difficult questions
um
today uh
let's see
um
Stephen asks do brains like ants and so
on
and bacteria have brains assuming they
do do they have emotions do they feel
pain in the case of bacteria which don't
have a brain what governs their behavior
well things like ants do have brains
we have about 100 billion nerve cells in
our brains and so about 50 000 in their
brains so answer much smaller brains
than we do but the stuff in their brains
is very similar to the stuff in human
brains it's a it's a network of neurons
and which are electrically affecting
each other and have pretty much the same
biochemistry as human brains have now
the question was asked do they have
emotions I think
emotions are probably the result of kind
of a a general kind of
sea of neurotransmitter something like
serotonin dopamine something like this
what some some chemical that kind of
washes over human brains and causes one
to have some emotional state probably
that's right probably it's not something
where it's the individual firings of
individual neurons it's rather a more
Collective effect that kind of bathes
the brain in some particular chemical
that leads it to have a general overall
uh kind of predisposition to be happy or
sad or whatever else it is and and that
sort of General bathing in that
neurotransmitter affects the individual
firings of particular neurons by tipping
them just a little bit in One Direction
versus another
so
does that effect happen in things like
ants my guess is yes
um I think they have the same
neurotransmitters that we do more or
less and my guess is that there are I
don't know whether anybody's ever
measured it
um there will be the same kind of
overall change
you know in human brains something that
you can often detect is where you can
certainly detect it is the EEG signal
that is the sort of the the while each
individual one of those 100 billion
neurons is kind of uh firing in response
to another neuron firing and there's a
little electrical pulse and so on
there's an overall Collective kind of uh
wave of of electrical activity in the
brain when you're awake it has one
particular form when you go to sleep it
has a different form and so on it's it's
pretty hard to interpret in detail and
people care a lot because for example
things like epilepsy are the results of
kind of that going out of control
um but or at least epilepsy in epilepsy
that goes out of control what's caused
what's effect is not so clear but um the
uh in any case the the thing that um
you can ask I believe the ants and
things like that do have a small EEG
signal but EEG is not generally related
to emotional states it's just something
that is kind of a collective aspect for
example you can tell you can you can
have some idea of whether things sleep
based on looking at different kinds of
eegs and so for example fish are known
to sleep in some sense and you can
detect that by looking at their EEG I
don't think that ants sleep
um I don't think they have the same sort
of uh very different kinds of EEG
signals that we have for example in when
we're awake versus asleep
but so I'm sort of guessing that ants
have some in some proxy for emotional
state based on neurotransmitters in
their brains and so on when you go to
lower organisms uh the um well for
example one that's very well studied is
a nematode C elegans that has um it's a
little critter with about how many is it
I think it's a couple of thousand cells
and um it's uh one thing about an
organism that small is it's kind of
genetically determined where every
single cell goes for us there's sort of
a general outline of oh we're going to
have the cells that make fingers and and
eyes and and brains and things like this
but the details of where each individual
cell goes in our bodies is not
determined genetically that's they it's
just the overall pattern that's
determined uh for something like a
nematode the um one of these C elegans
Critters sort of the position of every
single neuron is is every single cell is
determined now in that organism there is
something there are a bunch of nerve
cells there are hundreds of nerve cells
and the precise Circuit of connection
between those nerve cells is known
and and so you can do things like you
can see you know what is the effect of
stimulating the front of of the of the
Critter and does that cause it to
contract some muscle-like thing at the
back of the Critter things like this and
so there's a lot that's that's known
about how that works and for example
there are uh well I certainly remember
in a creature called aplasia which I
think is is very similar to the see
elegans you can see learning happening
you can see individual uh connections
between nerve cells getting strengthened
by the experiences the organism has or
getting uh reduced in intensity by the
experiences the organism has so in that
sense these things well they only have
hundreds of nerve cells with a very
definite sort of circuit there's still
something that's a bit like a brain
um and and where there is the
possibility of individual neuron
learning
um that's uh and what we've kind of
learned from the success of artificial
neural Nets in doing a lot of human-like
tasks is that it really does seem that
this idea of of learning by changing the
strengths of Weights between nerve cells
does seem to be something that is a an
adequate explanation of what's going on
and even things like human brains
now when you go down to things like
bacteria uh they're just single-celled
organisms and bacteria don't have kind
of the opportunity to have sort of
electrical signal type brains in the
same way that we do with lots of
different nerve cells and reactions
between those nerve cells what's uh but
it's still the case that bacteria can do
things where they sense their
environment and they have a reaction to
their environment so a very common kind
of thing is is the following that um
you'll have a little there'll be some
environment it's in maybe it has a lot
of sugar maybe it has not so much sugar
in the environment and maybe the the the
Critter wants to find sugar so it if
it's in a low sugar environment it wants
to just keep going in a straight line
like maybe it's an organism that has a
little flagella that are like a little
uh little sort of um
things that
wiggle to make the thing move
um and so what what it might do is uh
if it's in an area where there's not
much sugar it just wants to keep going
in a straight line in the hopes that it
will get to another area where there
might be more sugar but if it's in an
area where there's lots of sugar it's
really pretty happy to just stay where
it is and not move around but
nevertheless the way it works is it's
always got to be running these flagella
they were always keeping on sort of uh
um like little millipede feet or
something keeping on going
um and so a strategy it can use is if
it's in a place where there is uh where
it's happily got lots of sugar it'll
kind of keep randomly spinning around so
it won't keep in a consistent direction
it'll it'll spin itself around and so
it'll sort of randomly walk around and
not kind of systematically go out of
that region but if it's lower sugar it
will stop spinning around so much and it
will just keep going in a straight line
so the ability to do something like that
is a very uh sort of biochemically
determined thing the there are I don't
remember the exact signaling pathway for
that one but but essentially the
presence of one chemical leads to some
other chemical being produced inside the
bacterium which then leads to uh the
thing that leads to activity of the
flagella that move the thing around or
whatever else it is
um and uh that's so that's kind of a way
in which an organism like that can
essentially react to its environment
and it's it's not
within an individual organism the
organism doesn't seem to doesn't learn
um but what will happen in that case is
is that there will be sort of evolution
happening when this organism you know
every half an hour or something maybe
the organism will split in two and
they'll be that'll make two copies of it
there'll be two organisms then four then
eight and so on and depending on what
the environment is like every time that
division happens there'll be a small
change there'll be little random errors
that get made as the genetic material
gets replicated and uh uh then so some
of those bacteria will gradually be
slightly different and what will tend to
happen is the bacteria that are better
suited to the environment that the thing
is in those will replicate a little bit
faster they'll replicate a little bit
more and so there'll be more of those
bacteria and so gradually it will be as
if this sort of whole population of
bacteria is learning because there'll be
a sort of a a better a better bacterium
that's produced that will be the the
common thing that's produced
but I think
um
the uh so that's sort of behavior within
an organism is determined biochemically
behavior of a population of organisms
tends to be determined by by things like
um uh natural selection and evolution
there are some weird cases like there
are some things called slime molds that
are kind of these organisms that um a
collection of cells that form themselves
into very elaborate shapes and they do
that by uh that they're just molecules
that signal between those those
different cells
um and that cause the cells to arrange
themselves in different ways
you know there are other things there
may be some electrical phenomena that
happen even in things like bacteria I
think that's not really very well
understood
um and certainly there is some in the
way that biochemistry works there is
transport of both atoms and electrons
and whenever there's transport of
electrons it's kind of like there's an
electrical signal but it's a very it's
not like there's kind of a a great big
wire it's an electron it's being passed
from one molecule to another
um in a very very definite way I mean
that's something that happens in many in
many places in biology uh are sort of
what's really going on is there's this
sort of extra electron that got passed
from one molecule to another and so on
let's see
uh
oh boy you guys asked hard questions
Paula is asking how has it discovered
that caffeine could energize us are all
living things do all living things
experience these effects or is it
exclusive to humans
um
I don't know when coffee was discovered
I'm going to guess
that
it's a new world thing and it might have
been known uh
I don't know it probably was uh you know
written down
I'm thinking in in the 1500s or
something but I'm not sure
um and uh I think in the theory that
people tried eating almost everything
and saw what effect it had uh the um uh
you know that was probably something
quickly discovered
but
um I think the um
this question of whether
something like coffee
has caffeine has um uh what effect it
has on our brains versus what effect it
has on other brains
I think it has an effect on lots of
kinds of brains so for example I know
there are experiments where you take a
spider that's weaving its web and you
give it caffeine for example and it'll
go kind of hyperactive and it'll start
weaving its web in some crazy different
not very well organized way
um so at least despite a brain which I'm
guessing is kind of comparable to an ant
brain and maybe 50 000 neurons or so
um that seems to be affected chemically
in that same way and and my guess is
that it's something similar to it's kind
of you're kind of just changing the
characteristics of how every nerve cell
uh produces uh sort of produces its
electrical signals and so on and so it's
going to have an effect at a very basic
level to sort of anything that has nerve
cells that would be my guess
um
let's see
fortuitous asks if Electronics have
coils and the brain has
has coils should we be more conscious of
signals like radio signals and so on oh
this is a giant can of worms
um
so one of the questions is
in the modern environment there's all
kinds of radio signals all over the
place
and
there's been sort of a consistent belief
that radio signals at least at the
intensities that they typically are used
for communicating between devices and so
on really don't have biological effects
now if you have an intense enough radio
signal it absolutely has a biological
effect a microwave oven is an intense
radio signal typically tuned to the
frequency of the rotational band of
water which means the microwave oven is
is sort of putting electromagnetic
energy into things like food and taking
every water molecule in there and making
it spin around very rapidly and then
that spinning around gets transferred
into just heat of molecules moving
around in your food that's why if you
put ice in a microwave oven doesn't work
so well because it's not it's not able
to take like a water molecule and start
spinning it around because it's locked
in the ice in the Ice Cube but in any
case the um uh in a microwave oven there
is you're dealing with just essentially
radio waves
um but they're intense enough sort of
enclosed in that cavity that makes the
microwave oven and Amplified up they're
intense enough that you cook food and
things like this and you know you could
imagine that well you would
unfortunately cook yourself if you put
yourself in a microwave oven and there
are even various weapons that have been
tried to be built I'm not sure how
successfully I've directed microwave
weapons that will produce intense
microwave beams that will sort of cook
anything in its path so to speak so we
know that at the at the level of high
intensity you absolutely can have
biological effects from um
uh from electromagnetic waves from Radio
type type waves
uh now the question is when you get down
to the um uh
what is it two milliwatts I think
two no two watts is that right oh gosh
I'm forgetting what the um what the
standard is for cell phones
um but when you get down to the um uh
the the intensity of radio energy from a
cell phone can that have an effect can
you be sensitive to that I mean in in
the environment that we're in there's
there's lots of uh radio energy that's
in most places I mean there are cell
phones there the cell phones are
regularly Community even if you're not
talking on your cell phone it's
regularly doing little handshakes
communicating with a cell phone tower to
sort of check in and so on
then you know Wi-Fi uh communication
between computers there's continually
things being sent back and forth and
then even electrical wires uh in um
have uh 60 cycles per second of
alternating current electricity and that
produces a very low frequency
electromagnetic wave a kind of hum if
you were to play it on a on a kind of a
play it on a speaker so to speak but
that's another source of um
electromagnetic radiation
um and there's there's lots of sources
and the typical environment that we find
ourselves in with with lots of devices
and so on and so it's been a
long-running argument uh can that have a
biological effect or not and for example
you know you hold your cell phone up to
your your head
um you know is the electromagnetic
radiation that's being produced as the
cell phone tries to transmit uh radio
signals back to the cell phone tower is
that is that radio energy having an
effect on on you and your brain and so
on or not
I think the main conclusion is if
there's an effect it's not a dramatic
one you know there have been lots of
studies done of whether people you know
get more tumors when they use cell
phones and hold them up to their heads
and so on and the answer seems to be
probably not
um I think those studies are always very
hard because there's uh there's a lot of
kind of um uh you know vested interests
in in uh you know people want to use
cell phones companies that make cell
phones and so on want cell phones to be
used so it's a it's a high bar to say oh
there's something terrible about these
things they should uh people shouldn't
use them I mean I have to say uh
personally I tend to avoid kind of
holding a cell phone up to my head more
than I have to and I tend to just use a
headset and so on
um just because I don't I don't think
it's it's definitively clear that
there's no uh sort of cooking of the
brain so to speak that happens as a
result of of that like magnetic energy
there's no uh this there's there's a lot
of controversy about what's actually
what's actually even been found in
regards to those kinds of things and one
of the things people have certainly
noticed is that there are molecules that
have uh kind of helical structures and
so on that's a very common Motif in
proteins to have sulfur called Alpha
helices where pieces of the protein
where most of were made mostly of
proteins where where there's sort of
pieces of protein that are arranged in a
kind of helical pattern and that helical
pattern is kind of like a tiny uh you
can think of it like a tiny anti Anna if
there's electromagnetic energy
um there you can end up with something
where yes it will make the electrons in
that Helix they'll it will push them a
little bit around that Helix and that's
a little bit like what happens in a in a
typical radio antenna does that have an
effect I don't think we know
um could it have an effect well yes
potentially
um but you know the effect might be so
infinitesimally small as to be
irrelevant
um and uh you know it could be that that
yes there's an effect of the um
uh you know the the radio energy from
the cell phone but there's a lot more
effect if you put your hand on your head
or something that that has a a bigger
effect because the effect is so tiny I
don't think we know
so
it is the case that cell phones do tend
to adjust the amount of energy that
they're putting out based on whether
they think you're holding them up to
your head or even holding them at all
and there's a whole elaborate protocol
for sensing the fact that a hand is
holding a cell phone and what that means
in terms of the intensity radiation
that's that's being produced and so on
um and in an attempt to kind of uh if
there is a biological effect to prevents
it being uh so dramatic but I think um
the uh
um the question is
I suppose can people
um
kind of uh can people sense the presence
of electromagnetic radiation
um in somewhere in the brain and the
answer is uh that it's complicated that
there's there's not there's not a lot of
evidence that they can but there are
some limiting cases where they can for
example
I don't know this is a very good
scientific fact
I know 40 years ago or something when I
was uh interested in experiments in
particle physics and experiments in
particle physics often involve having
huge magnets that are intended to
deflect particles so you can tell what
the charge of the particle was things
like that and the question was if you
just hang out if you walk inside one of
these big magnets can you tell you're
inside a big Magnet or not
and people always used to say that
you've got a funny taste in your mouth
when there was a big magnetic field it's
possible the the there's certainly some
electrochemistry that happens in taste
that could be affected by that
um I don't think that happens when
people get MRIs for example which also
involve High magnetic fields although
maybe not as high as those particle
physics experiments so that's kind of a
point against that kind of detection now
I also mentioned the case of pigeons
where it's believed that pigeons sense
the magnetic field of the earth which is
really weak a million times weaker than
the magnetic field in an MRI machine or
something like this
um the uh the thing that um
uh it's believed that
the most likely thing is that there are
sort of individual atoms
um whose uh whose orientation is
basically affected by the magnetic field
of the earth and there are things in the
brains of pigeons that sense those well
if pigeon haven't we might have them too
and that might mean we could sense
electromagnetic fields I don't know
um I have to say
I personally to to say something
absolutely weird about myself
um had long had the experience that if I
if I handle uh strong magnets my fingers
tingle
I don't know why I don't know whether
that's really a real effect or not I
have to say I've not done good
experiments on it my children at one
point tried to do some experiments on me
and claimed that the results were deeply
inconclusive but I'm not sure and but
it's certainly something where I really
haven't looked into it adequately and I
haven't done the adequate experiments
but something where I certainly wondered
you know can the presence of a of a like
a rare earth Magnet or something and as
you move the real life magnet around it
will induce electric fields in your
fingers and you know can you sense those
things and maybe yes I don't know
um I think uh this is a it's a it's a
it's an area where you know things are
not well understood or well known
um and I think this this whole question
of sort of the the biological effects of
uh well magnetic fields
uh small radio
small amounts of radio energy those
kinds of things not not really very well
known as I say if you have enough radio
energy it'll cut things so that then
then it's very clear what happens uh you
know that they're uh
uh but it's it's a um uh it's one of
those things that's currently unclear
and people might worry that well
something that's changed in the world is
that well now we have lots of uh radio
things bouncing around and um uh that
might have some some biological effect
people wonder for example about uh 5G
um where actually I think that the the
way that 5G works it's very inefficient
to have a signal going from your cell
phone instead of going out in all
directions to get to a cell phone tower
one of the things about 5G is attempting
to arrange things so the signal only
goes in a very particular direction so
in the end that probably means unless
you happen to be always in in where the
signal is going so to speak that
probably means there's less radio energy
concentrated in some particular area
than there would be with earlier kinds
of radio Technologies because because
basically the way that you opt optimize
things is always to just have the signal
go from the place where it's being
transmitted to the place where it's
being received and not to just spread
out in all directions and only a tiny
bit of it happens to go in the right
direction but that it goes out in all
directions and only tiny bit goes in the
right direction that's the sort of
traditional way that radio works you
have to do much more elaborate things
so-called phased arrays where you're
basically having multiple pieces of an
antenna and the pieces of the antenna
are kind of producing uh radio waves in
in such a way that the phases of those
radio waves interfere so that you
concentrate all the energy in a
particular direction and that's kind of
the idea there
um
so uh somebody is commenting that yes
the
um uh cell phones go up there two Watts
that's right that's the that's the
that's the standard number and I think
they they usually operate when you're
holding them they think they operate
usually about half a watt
um it's always a an interesting
challenge when if you're just at the
edge of where cell phone reception is is
uh is a real thing you know can you
improve the cell phone reception by sort
of attaching yourself as an antenna so
to speak to the cell phone and usually
most cell phones the the antenna kind of
goes well they're different patterns but
a common thing is to have the the outer
case of the cell phone be part of the
antenna and so you know you can actually
by holding the thing you can make some
level of electrical connection to it and
you can potentially be sort of part of
the antenna or not and I I have to say
it's it's
um
yeah it's it's uh
let's see maybe one more
question here
uh Jamie is asking
um
is there a reason for food likes and
dislikes that each person experiences
can taste buds be tricked
well
the
taste buds are really complicated things
they in the end taste like smell
is presumably associated with the way
that particular molecules in food
particular molecules have arranged
themselves on molecules that are in
taste buds or whatever else
and and so what happens is you know the
food gets kind of crushed up and it gets
mixed in with saliva and so on and
partly dissolved and all these kinds of
things and then in the end it's okay the
food has a certain shape of molecule and
the taste bud has a whole arrangement of
different kinds of molecules in it Each
of which has a different shape and
presumably what's happening is the
biggest effect is well does the shape of
one molecule the lime or the shape or
another molecule do these things stick
together if they do stick together then
the result of that is eventually to
produce a nerve signal
um to to make a nerve cell fire and that
nerve cell the the electrical effect
from that nerve cell goes to your brain
and you say oh I'm tasting something
well
there are some things that are known so
for example
it presumably is the case that the
actual molecules that occur in those
taste buds and the shapes of those
molecules are determined by the whole
sort of genetic plan for the organism
and so there are particular things no
and oh gosh what are they they're things
like weather
uh some foods taste bitter or not maybe
asparagus maybe it's one of I'm not sure
there's there's a um oh no no there's a
there's some certain herbs that um uh
taste better to some people and not to
others and it's knowing that there's a
genetic kind of correlate of those
things that is people whose genome has a
particular sequence in a particular
place they'll make a particular protein
the protein will be a particular shape
that particular shape will or won't fit
in with that particular kind of plant or
whatever it is or the the the the
proteins that exist in that particular
kind of plant and so some set of people
will genetically tend to uh like that
kind of food or that kind of food will
taste better or or whatever else and
it's always amusing to you know I know
with with my kids for example that they
have definite preferences in food that
seem to be even with sort of blind
experimentation
seem to be similar to ones that I have
and so that's presumably or maybe that's
a a nurture phenomenon of uh those were
things that um were around when they
were growing up but I think there's
enough different cases of this that
that's probably not true and that it
really is a a genetic predisposition to
like raspberries or something like this
and that presumably comes because the
actual sort of shapes of molecules that
exist in taste buds which are
genetically determined
um run in in families and so on like
that now in in terms of uh
what uh you know things that taste good
versus don't taste good it's always
amazing that the sort of details of how
food is presented and how it's been
crushed up and whether it's got a big
surface area or not or whether it's in
little tiny particles or not or how it's
mixed with other things those have big
effects on the perception of taste and I
I also tend to think that you know when
people talk about such and such a thing
as an acquired taste there's some
process by which we can kind of get used
to a particular taste and start to
quotes like it and it's maybe not a
thing where we are necessarily you know
born liking this or not liking that I
know in the course of my life there are
things that where I really didn't like
them back 50 years ago and I've come to
find them really pretty good foods in in
later years
um and so it's it's a um uh
it's a it's it's sort of a thing which
can definitely change
um now I think that there are sort of
things that come with the species of
things we tend to like like we tend to
like sweet things and uh well why is
that I mean we can answer that at a
couple of levels I think one is that the
the question of sort of how our brain is
wired up to respond to different kinds
of things there's a certain amount of
the wiring of the brain that's been
determined by Evolution and presumably
some of that wiring is set up so that
the the wiring we got is the wiring
that's been evolutionarily more
successful so for example wiring that
says uh kind of walk right off a cliff
um is is probably wiring that is not
going to survive evolutionarily because
if everybody with that wiring walks off
a cliff they won't have kids and they
won't have kids who inherit that that
tendency to walk off a cliff and so
similarly it tends to be the case for
example sweet things are probably are
good sources you know glucose is what
gives us energy and things like that
it's a well part of part of it at least
the the the
um
those are things that are sort of uh are
a have a positive effect on us when we
eat them in some sense they they give us
they quickly give us energy so if we're
you know if we have to figure out you
know oh we're going to run away from the
mammoth or something like this oh you
know it's a good thing to have eaten
some glucose when we're running away
from the mammoth so the folks who
learned oh it's a good thing to eat
glucose
um and liked eating glucose uh will be
ones who will be more successful in
running away from the mammoth and
therefore they'll be the ones that have
more children and things like this and
so that will become a trait that gets
burnt into the species so I think that's
um uh but but you know this whole
question of of um
um
you know I think this question of what
we like and what we don't like it's
probably also correlated with uh sort of
our our whole set of experiences like
you know it can probably matter what the
packaging of the food is whether there's
food coloring that makes the food some
horrible color versus some really
attractive color those things probably
all have an effect and we probably learn
from the fact that oh we think that's a
really uh nice color of of of candy or
something like this and we then say
that's a nice color of candy then we
taste it then we associate that taste
with oh we like that thing and then
pretty soon we're oh we like the taste
of that thing so I think it's it's a um
uh um it's a it's a
you know it's it's a complicated
collection of exp of uh of connections
um you know I I do think
that
you know I I don't know when it comes to
for example kids who say I don't like
food X so why
um I was certainly one of those kids
some of my kids have been of the of that
type too and one of the embarrassing
things for me is some of the things
where I said I don't like them refused
to eat it when I was a kid uh and now uh
really popular foods for me and and what
happened did my sense of taste change or
did I just sort of learn different
associations with that food I'm really
not sure
um I think also another Dynamic that
happens is that our body is pretty good
at sensing what we need so to speak and
so you know you'll have you know the
craving for this or that kind of food
and it'll be like there there seems to
be a feedback mechanism that seems to be
of a chemical nature that says oh you
haven't had enough of of this you know
you need a food that has that kind of
thing in it you know you need more iron
or something you know you you have uh
you you you crave this kind of food I'm
not sure how well understood all those
kinds of things are but that's a
mechanism by which uh we're kind of you
know our our brains are connected to the
the things which are sensing the fact oh
yes we ate food that has this or that in
it
um and and then we we either want more
of it or we don't
all right well I should probably wrap up
there
um thanks for a lot of questions some of
which were kind of difficult today
um
and uh look forward to doing this
another time and uh on what I just uh
logistical point on on Fridays I've been
kind of alternating between doing this
General q a about science and technology
and doing Q a about future of Science
and Technology and so next week I think
we'll be doing a future of Science and
Technology q a and I encourage people
who are interested in getting questions
answered please send them on the
submission forms that we have and even
if you don't have a chance to uh
see this live stream live in real time
uh I think our system is such that if
you leave your email address when you
send in the question uh we'll send you
mail if I got the chance to answer that
question you can check it out in the
archive of the live stream
all right well thanks for joining me and
uh bye for now